en hausse sur les marchés
et la demande de biocarburant
ne fait qu'accélérer la cadence.
Marie-Josée Paquette Comeau.
- Dans les friteuses de La frite
à Mon'oncle, les patates
baignent dans l'huile de canola.
Mon'oncle, Mario, en utilise
en grande quantité.
- Facilement entre
500 et 600 litres par mois.
- À une telle quantité,
une hausse de prix est dure
pour le portefeuille.
MARIO LEGAULT, copropritaire
de La frite à Mon'oncle
- L'huile de canola,
effectivement, les prix
ont doublé.
- Pour sa cantine, le prix est
passé de 1,18 $ le litre, il y a
quelques mois, à 2,10 $.
DENIS LANDRY, directeur général
de Groupe prestige
- Le transformateur,
mon boulanger ou mon pâtissier,
paie deux fois ce qu'il payait
à la même date l'an passé
pour son huile de canola.
- Denis Landry approvisionne
environ 60 PME au Québec
en huile alimentaire.
- Le blé, c'est 40 % de hausse,
la matière première, le maïs,
c'est 65 % de hausse. Le soya,
la "soy bean oil", comme je vous
ai dit tantôt, c'est 100...
près de 80 % de hausse avec
l'an passé. Ça, j'avais jamais
vu ça, là, t'sais.
- Ces hausses sont dues
à de mauvaises récoltes de soya
en 2020 en Amérique du Sud.
La rareté a provoqué une flambée
des prix sur les marchés
boursiers. C'est sans compter
l'augmentation de la demande
de biocarburant.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU,
professeur, HEC Montréal
- Au Québec, on a pris
la décision de monter de 2 à 4 %
d'ici 2025 la quantité
de biodiesel qui devra être
mélangée au diesel.
Et pour l'éthanol, c'est passé
de 10 à 15 % d'ici 2025.
- À cela s'ajoute le nouveau
règlement fédéral sur
les combustibles propres qui
devrait entrer en vigueur
en décembre 2022. Il vise
à diminuer les gaz à effet
de serre en augmentant
le pourcentage de biocarburant
dans les combustibles fossiles.
- Comme la principale production
d'éthanol vient du maïs, bien
ça va mettre en concurrence
les producteurs de carburants
avec le secteur de
l'alimentation.
- Une compétition qui hausse les
prix jusque dans nos assiettes.
- On est obligés d'ajuster
nos prix. Cette année,
on l'a ajusté un petit peu.
- Mais qu'à cela ne tienne
pour ceux qui ne paient pas
l'addition.
- La poutine,
c'est la meilleure.
- Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, R.-C., Mont-Roll